it is a parent's worst nightmare your
child's School in lockdown police and
ambulances surrounding the grounds for
hundreds of parents this was the reality
at Tewkesbury Academy this morning in
gloucestershire Sarah's 13 year old
daughter Izzy was inside it just sat at
her as a parent
you know when something's happening with
your children and you can't do anything
about it so we decided to come and then
she texts me back to just say that she
says frightened
in those texts Izzy told her mum it's
really scary we are stuck in a classroom
mum I'm really scared I know darling
Sarah replied but the police are there
and sorting it out I love you so much
they had guns as he added they had armed
police
Emergency Services were called just
after nine o'clock to report to male
teacher had been stabbed by a pupil in a
school Corridor a widespread search for
the suspect then began
especially this Resort
s including the National Police Air
Service and plane close officers were
deployed to search The Wider area and
thanks to their efforts the suspect was
safely arrested by Firearms officers in
Stoke Orchard at 11 o'clock this morning
during the arrest around six miles away
from the school a knife was seized the
motive behind this attack here is still
unclear but police say at this stage
there is no evidence to suggest that
it's that it's terrorism related
the teenage boy is being questioned on
suspicion of attempted murder the
teacher named locally as Jamie Sansum
has tonight been discharged from
hospital
for the parents it was an agonizing wait
at the school gates to be reunited with
their children for Sarah and Izzy's
sister Emily sheer relief to be back
together after the most terrifying of
days
Dan why did Sky News in Shrewsbury
gloucestershire